à la droite il y a quelques minutes la
droite et le centre du Sénat viennent de
voter ce qu'ils appellent le CDI senior
c'est à dire un contrat pour inciter les
entreprises à embaucher plus de seniors
notamment à partir de 60 ans pourquoi
cette opposition de la gauche dans ce
débat alors que c'est plutôt une mesure
pour favoriser l'emploi non ça
favorisera pas du tout l'emploi vous
savez ça m'a rappelé mon engagement en
politique en 2006 j'ai manifesté avec
des millions de de personnes et beaucoup
de jeunes contre le Contrat Première
Embauche qui était déjà destiné à
embaucher les jeunes avec des
exonérations massives de cotisations
sociales c'est exactement la même chose
c'est un contrat dernier embauche qu'on
nous propose avec des exonérations de
cotisations une nouvelle fois qui ne
fonctionne pas j'ai rappelé d'ailleurs
dans l'hémicycle le rapport sur le cice
vous savez c'est 20 milliards d'euros de
cotisations on nous promettait avec
François Hollande oui avec un badge vous
rappelez pierre Gattaz 1 million
d'emplois
ça crée 100 000 emplois ça fait cher
quand même pour 18 milliards chaque
année c'est 180000 euros
subventions à l'emploi quand le salaire
médian et aux alentours chargé de
cotisations 33000 vous voyez donc ça ne
marche pas on sait que les exonérations
pas besoin de démultiplier les CDI les
CDD les contrats de dernière embauche si
on veut agir sur l'emploi alors il y a
besoin de d'agir avec les entreprises et
les contraintes par la loi vous n'y
arriverez pas avec des exonérations
massives ça ne fonctionne pas et
d'ailleurs la dernière chose c'est que
le ministreal a eu raison on va scier là
aussi la branche famille de la sécurité
sociale c'est 3 à 4 milliards d'euros de
côté d'exonération de cotisations qui va
compenser l'État au début
3 à 4 milliards à trouver sur cinq ans
peut-être que sur les cinq premières
années l'État exonera et après
compensera pardon et après donc c'est
une très mauvaise mesure elle ne
fonctionne pas elle a prouvé son
inefficacité et en plus
nous on est ravis de cette journée on
sera un pied dans la rue aux côtés du
mouvement social un pied dans
l'hémicycle évidemment pour continuer à
combattre ce projet de contre-réforme
mais oui il faut en venir à l'article 7
on verra si c'est demain on verra si
c'est mercredi on verra si c'est
peut-être jeudi peu importe nous on ne
fait pas d'obstruction la seule
obstruction qu'il y a ici c'est une
obstruction silencieuse de la part de la
droite qui ne refuse de débattre nous on
avance et on en viendra l'article 7
comme ça sera le temps mais il faudrait
que la gauche peut-être retire certains
amendements pour arriver demain plus
vite il faudrait surtout que la droite
arrête cette obstruction silencieuse et
débattre parce que pour un débat
monsieur Poussard X2 si vous débattez
tout seul et que je réponds aucune
question il y a pas d'interview mais
voyez un débat parlementaire c'est
pareil il faut être deux donc la gauche
elle elle agit tranquillement on avance
un certain nombre d'arguments je crois
que depuis le début personne peut dire
qu'il y a eu des arguments un peu un peu
fou on avance et il faut que la droite
débatte avec nous que les ministres
répondent et puis on arrivera
tranquillement l'article qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de cette journée de
manifestation et de grève demain c'est
le début du blocage du pays ah bah
écoutez beaucoup et je sais que ça va
être énorme on le voit partout dans les
grandes villes dans les villages dans
les sous-préfectures partout sur le
territoire des dizaines des centaines de
points sont annoncés de de
manifestations la grève doit être
massive dans les transports EDF je tiens
les saluer ils ont commencé des week-end
à reprendre leur routier industriel en
main dans le privé dans le public un
certain nombre de collectivités seront
fermés parce que tous les fonctionnaires
seront en grève et il faut que les
mobilisations et les manifestations sont
le plus massif bon mais nous ça va nous
donner du baume au coeur et je vous je
vous avoue qu'on attend le 7 avait très
grande et pas si je suis pas sûr que les
ministres ou la droite sénatoriale soit
dans le même état d'esprit nous on est
très heureux mais ça donnera du baume au
coeur à la gauche pour les débats demain
sur l'article 7 le report de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans et ce sera à suivre
et bien en direct sur Public Sénat allez
on retourne dans l'hémicycle ou les
sénateurs continuent à débattre de cette
réforme des retraites
[Musique]